bonjour alexandre langlois et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt franc je venais
de le dire 35 décès en donnait 18 contre
59 l'année dernière on voit une grosse
augmentation du taux de suicide dans la
police pourquoi selon vous alors bonjour
elle est déjà on voit une grosse
augmentation depuis que monsieur
castaner est là parce qu'il faut savoir
déjà sur l'année 2018
en reprenant des deux mois au castaner
était ministre nous avons eu droit à 10
suicides dire que sur les 35 en a dix
qui se sont passé les deux derniers mois
sous la direction de monsieur castaner
et le mouvement n'a fait que s'amplifier
car aujourd'hui monsieur castaner a
depuis qu'il a pris la direction de la
police nationale à compter 73 suicide
également nous avons notre directeur
général de la police nationale qui part
à la retraite anticipée épuisés qui a
comptabilisé sous ses ordres 113 suicide
alors pourquoi parce qu'il ya un malaise
dans la police nationale depuis des
années qui n'est pas la responsabilité
de ce gouvernement mais qui a été
amplifié par une actualité sociale et
anti terroriste très augmenté par
rapport à d'autres années et avec des
gens qui ne savent absolument pas nous
diriger qu'on continue et d'amplifier
tout le malaise qu'il y avait dans notre
institution heures supplémentaires
accumulées à gogo syrte nous sommes
passés depuis que monsieur ce
gouvernement-là de 22 millions d'heures
supplémentaires à 25 millions d'heures
supplémentaires
on ne veut pas nous payer nos heures
supplémentaires ou sinon moins chers que
leurs habituels on nous fait faire des
missions qui sont contre les valeurs
pour lesquelles nous nous sommes engagés
vers au service de la population de la
république et venant de répression
sociale
il y a également toujours cette
politique du chiffre qui a été on nous
demande de remplir des statistiques
plutôt que d'assurer la sécurité de la
population
ce qui est complètement différent donc
il ya tout un ensemble de choses qui
font qu'on arrive à ce sujet là la
dernière chose et c'est pour ça que je
suis très heureux qu'ils aient une
enquête ouverte par le parquet à saint
nazaire c'est qu'un système managérial
délétère dans la police nationale qui
fait que quand on refuse tout ces hordes
ces statistiques c'est des choses qui
nous met mal à l'aise il ya une pression
hiérarchique une sorte de harcèlement
moral qui permet les pins qui pousse nos
collègues à ces actes dramatiques
on l'a vu le ministère de l'intérieur a
mis en place une cellule de soutien
psychologique est primordial selon vous
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des retours
sur son utilisation
alors déjà pour commencer cette cellule
psychologique le ministère n'a tellement
pas mis d'argent il n'avait vraiment
rien à faire à part faire la
communication c'est que le premier appel
d'offres qui a été sur un marché public
a été mis en avril il n'a pas trouvé
preneur en juillet ils ont dû faire un
nouvel appel d'offres ensuite payé des
collègues qui ont utilisé cette ligne on
leur dit voilà il ya quelqu'un qui dit
qui décroche de temps en temps il ya un
serveur s'est redirigée sur mais c'est
vraiment très impersonnel et très froid
dans un moment où on est en difficulté
déjà on ne m'appelle pas un service
téléphonique 24 heures sur 24 c'est
complètement être déconnecté de la
réalité on a besoin de contacts humains
de contact avec des personnes qui nous
aident que réellement et en fait on
n'appellera jamais cycling au bon moment
c'est un sparadrap sur une jambe de bois
un effet de communication qui devait
coûter le moins cher possible comme le
laisse ou mis sur la table ont pu le
prouver
selon vous quelles sont les mesures des
mesures d'urgence à mettre en place pour
prévenir ces suicides mais les mesures
d'urgence nous est ce qu'on préconise
depuis très longtemps c'est déjà d'avoir
un management humain dire que notre
directeur général de la police nationale
en 2019 avait fait une note de service
ordonnant au chef de service de faire
preuve d'empathie
je veux dire déjà ordonné de faire
preuve d'empathie ça montre une certaine
déconnexion de la réalité
après il nous avait proposé également
des barbecues conviviaux en nous disant
ben vous voyez passer votre famille mais
je vous propose de faire des petits
barbecue sur votre temps te personnel
pas sur votre temps de travail
donc en fait on a des gens qui n'ont
rien à faire donc pour ça se range le
management doit être plus humain donc au
niveau du recrutement on aura été de
recruter des cadres très brillant
intellectuellement mais où est ce qui
prend le côté humain l'empathie le site
et les compétences de management qui
sont très difficiles à acquérir par la
suite parce que j'ai raté mes
compétences innées même chose également
il faudrait qu arrêter que soit la
police des polices enquête sur la police
l'igpn à france télécom-orange quand il
ya eu 19 suicide
eh bien ce n'est pas france
télécom-orange qui avait fait les
enquêtes en lisant problèmes personnels
circulez il n'ya rien à voir dans la
police est toujours le cas
et donc pour éviter tout ça et mettre un
petit peu nos responsables devant leurs
responsabilités
notre syndicat avait déposé plainte en
septembre et nous sommes en attente du
retour du procureur dernière question on
en est à les sources diffèrent on en est
à 2 à 3 trois suicides en ce début
d'année sur le mois de janvier
uniquement
nous sommes à trois suicides depuis le
détroit ccid tout début janvier nous
avons un collègue du service de
protection des personnalités qui s'est
défenestrée du 6e étage
après deux ans d'arrêt maladie pour
dépression
que dire que l'administration plutôt que
d'aller l'aider de faire remonter la
pente a préféré le laisser mourir a
effectivement ça fait des économies pour
les retraites c'est un fonctionnaire de
moins à gérer mais c'est complètement
inhumain
d'ailleurs petite anecdote dans la
police nationale nous n'avons pas de
direction des ressources humaines
nous avons une direction des ressources
et des compétences le mot il m'a déjà
été rayés de la du service du personnel
et après nous avons deux collègues notre
collègue de saint nazaire qui se sud est
chez elle et nous avons également un
collègue de rennes au centre de
rétention administrative
merci beaucoup alexandre l'envoi pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
vie merci à vous